well obviously really strong they get to
train amongst many of the best players
so really grind out the matchup and he's
got he's got us you know as well as
generally like an offensive character
right but he's got a star where he likes
to do things like back off and get the
arrow lethal hit teleported and
follow-up so he you sometimes you can't
really tell when you want some kind of
when he wants to run away and if you're
not ready for that that bold change from
him if you will be really dangerous
that's definitely been one of the
strengths for new beside as he's made
his way through this tournament one of
the reasons why he's gotten to the top
pages a lot of people haven't been able
to get a read on him in neutral honestly
know he likes to run sometimes and the
only person that had that put him into
losers
that was the only time he got into
losers was because that so don't break
the couple noodle cup my friend
photographers he doesn't kill anyone
[Music]
right now so jin-hwan was top eight last
year this year he was fourth place yes
this year he was top 16 I want to say
you got 13 place
instead of six previous time well to be
fair last year you play junghwa and
trick freed but or was it Sophie oh it's
been a little spin I'll have to check it
again I'm sorry he did play some Sophie
but yes this time he was playing mostly
Junction's okay so you know an excellent
competitor when is Singapore is it - you
know the whole Shen clan is it's just
it's just a wonderful set of players
another person who understands over
there shaking also known as heat one of
the better sick breeds in the business
okay yeah so she reverses as well
Cervantes versus as well is is nigh
impossible is what most
servantes places and I am inclined to
agree to be quite honest with you the
track record this matchup doesn't seem
much easier to me don't get me wrong
this guy is need to Europe right now
okay he's he's one of the best in the
biz but you know you you better get
pretty lucky on when you get your
stances I feel like sometimes well I
mean it helps him out to get in the top
eight he hats up beat its hero right so
we're gonna have to see it right here
new besides though he's kind of a wall
water fight back step into the side set
right there to get out of range and then
out of the move my turn right back at
you I can step to my friend you ski to
school who I was gonna say I love the
patience and then I'm right there it
even paid off a little bit stronger Wow
Kent
caught him thinking about the matchups
just outside a range you know new
besides table spacing has been some of
the best I've ever seen to be honest
with you
this is what I was saying about his
style sometimes he's in sometimes he's
out and probably not that fun for tiro
we'll see what shin-chan can do good
effects also there's a wallet on a pick
side
you tried to our ion wake up and
unfortunately or maybe fortunately for
Shanshan you know he was nice of patient
negative 12
yeah which means I get that hit foot
Terra has one of the best negative
twelve are the best night well France
yeah but the range is a little bit short
that's the only weakness of it
how's it matter if he's in your grille
right yes she died
oh yeah right that was level two he
expected a regio but no dice leukocytes
a patient he trying to sidestep throw
but it actually crushed under it GI guy
coming out at this time he did get her I
think this might be death
barely got a pixel but again we get a
nice big mix-up shin-chan looking super
strong in adherence this this seems to
be a lot easier for him
matchup wise then there's amethyst and I
wonder if that's agree it critter it
could also be a lot of practice right
and if it a bit like solely trying to
figure this matchup out wits hero and so
he may have just a lot of hours under
the belt i remember prior to this he
tried cueing verses as well that matchup
is not bad to be honest although he's
making this look amazing
don't get me wrong so charge for dogs
right now a lot of aggressive options
for both of them a day plus because oh
it's roll
oh not a suck on the low block right
there look what it afforded to him in
fact gloomy right now Oh in the mid
horizontal an incredible play right
there from Shanshan hey I like how he
kept up with his tech role first and
then went for the horizontal just to see
if he would try to move or stay there
yeah that was a really good read on the
tech world to be honest you know just
one step to the right and he knew so you
know I would say the only things that
did not match suicidality block and you
know you know sometimes the match is
really fast-paced you just feel like you
want to move or you're trying to tell
whether it's okay to attack on wakeup or
not right but I think that he gave away
a lot of those rounds just laying
shin-chan finish to go for the basic mid
after a knockdown and maybe if we block
and tried to try it a little higher to
go for the comeback he might be able to
cut down some duck dim outside of the
razor and spiteful on on the one he's
partying now that is definitely the next
guest character in the NBA Jam 2020 game
you know you want to get a little bit of
that back mid bid oh my goodness even
the throws are coming out like you know
we see him holding guard a lot but he's
just getting put in worse and worse
situations and now shin-chan is on set
point I feel like shin-chan understood
how the previous game it was a heating
block allowed asking right so this time
it's almost like you could smell that
you decide once to block oh my goodness
luckily for knew beside you got Pig
damage right there on the whip oh my
goodness it did a lot more yeah I
believe that's new to this version right
I have an idea I can you don't know this
hacker that will oh but [ __ ] that
definitely does moving on right there
sham sham so that was that was a flex I
could see the pecs come out bro like
[Music]
shin-chan steerer looks like the terror
versus Annie as well he's come up
against thus far no sick give me some
cup noodles right now that's how good
that oh you get some right here yeah I
guess see I'm stir-fry now I don't want
to get him said that sounds crazy anyway
guys so we've seen a lot of really great
top eight matches so far oh these guys
have been joined up winner's bracket
especially is gonna be super excited we
got you total who was the standard Evo
champ has a good chance that can you
take the entire day here in good Japan
as well yeah versus blue God and that's
actually gonna be a run back from evo
2019 grand finals